[Music]
system administrators possess great
power
i'm eric gray from vmware and in this
video i'll show you how to improve the
security posture of your google cloud
vmware engine private cloud by setting
up active directory authentication to
allow for better visibility into actions
by individual vsphere admins
by default google cloud vmware engine
provides one admin account called cloud
owner
to make certain infrastructure
configuration changes such as changing
authentication sources you must
temporarily elevate the privileges
after a selectable time interval the
privileges will automatically revert
before continuing ad authentication you
will need to set up dns forwarding for
your private cloud to resolve on-prem
addresses
dns profile configuration was covered in
the previous video in this series
once the elevation is effective log into
the vsphere client from the vmware
engine portal and navigate to
administration
under single sign-on select
configuration and add a new identity
source
the type must be active directory over
ldap
the integrated windows authentication
type is not supported
complete the required fields according
to your ad configuration to encrypt
traffic between vcenter server and the
ad domain controllers use ldap over ssl
and upload appropriate certificates
see vmware kb article
204-1378 for more information
after you create the identity source the
next step is to grant privileges to ad
users
there are different approaches a simple
way is to add individual ad users to the
cloud owner group
while it is possible to add ad groups
selecting specific individuals offers
better visibility from the vcenter
perspective and could reduce the chance
that unintended users are granted
vsphere admin privileges via active
directory
another option is to clone or create a
new role with desired privileges and
then explicitly add users and
permissions in the vcenter inventory
[Music]
to test the new identity source log out
of cloud owner and log in using active
directory credentials
ensure that the permissions granted
provide expected access within vcenter
you gain visibility and improve security
when you require vsphere admins to use
individual accounts instead of sharing a
single administrator login to learn more
about google cloud vmware engine visit
our site at cloud.google.com
vmware dash engine
[Music]
you